[Musique]
de par les temps qui courent ce que nous
pensons être des causes de vienne en
réalité des conséquences nous courons
après des buts qui se révèle n'être que
de simples moyens
l'effet voulu se métamorphosent petit à
petit en effet secondaire d'ailleurs ce
que je viens de dire est à la fois ma
conclusion est mon point de départ au
[Applaudissements]
donc je m'appelle jacques je suis
musicien je rêve de réussir dans la
musique et j'aimerais bien en fait
réussir à écrire des chansons qui
plaisent aux gens et je me rends compte
qu'en fait pas ce que les gens aiment
comme musique pas fait pas les chansons
que j'écris donc je me rends compte que
peut-être que mon rêve en fait c'est de
réussir à faire aimer aux gens ce que
moi j'aime jouer j'aime écrire mais je
vais pas vous parler de musique
en fait moi je suis là parce que j'ai 22
ans et que je suis donc en âge de
révolte je suis officiellement dans
l'âge de la rébellion et je suis un âge
donc on se couche très tard le soir on
boit de l'alcool on prend des drogues
ont fait tout un tas d'expériences et
j'ai donc souvent l'occasion de discuter
avec des gens super cool de comment le
système ne marche pas pourquoi ils
disent fonctionne de cette façon et
comment nous allons réussir à mieux le
pt ou comment nous allons réussir à en
sortir complètement
alors moi je vous dis tout de suite je
ne veux pas changer le monde je veux pas
changer le monde
certains d'entre vous sont en train
peut-être de penser si à son âge c'est
normal de se rebeller
alors ne pas se révéler ça constitue
peut-être une certaine forme de
rébellion suivie changer le monde c'est
une question subtil c'est justement
parce que c'est une question se peut-il
que j'ai du mal à avoir un avis tranché
c'est à dire que j'ai j'arrive je vais
avoir une discussion de sociologie
d'histoire d'économie et en fait je vais
avoir plein d'avis qu'ils sont pareils
parade ictoi paradoxal contre 1 je
n'arrive pas à me caler sur un seul avis
et c'est rigolo parce que je m'appelle
jacques mon prénom donc c'est jacques et
un s à la fin déjà que ça fait un peu
comme si j'avais plusieurs jacques à
l'intérieur de moi même donc en fait
c'est ce que je disais donc voilà je
suis animé par plusieurs jacques et
c'est comme si jacques plus jacques
donnez jacques j'aimerais faire le point
avec vous sur les différents jacques qui
m'anime et je voulais je vous en tirez
différents portraits en fait j'ai mes
différents jacques on certain esprit de
révolte
parfois d'autres essaient de faire des
compromis donc voilà je vais me dévoiler
un peu je vous présente jacques le
normal
c'est moi qui joue avec le normal c'est
le degré zéro de la rébellion c'est le
mec il est voilà vous le dit quelque
chose il le fait ils obéissent et voilà
c'est le gars il se pose pas de
questions ils n'aiment pas avoir un avis
voilà il n'aime pas en fait allé à
l'encontre de la majorité donc en fait
c'est lui va porter des habits normaux
tout est pour lui tu le monde c'est
comme ça un point c'est tout il se pose
pas trop de questions et lui grâce à lui
c'est lui qui m'a expliqué que par
exemple il ya des choses qui comptent
pas remettre en question par exemple là
mais je porte un pantalon il faut porter
un pantalon tous les jours en toutes
circonstances parce que sinon il ya des
gens ils vont plus me parler vous dire
là où au moins si c'est pas un pantalon
faut que ce soit caché à ce niveau là
parce que sinon les gens ils parlent
plus quoi donc
donc oui il m'a fait comprendre ça il
m'a aussi fait comprendre un truc qui
m'a dit un jour et m'a dit tu vas voir
il ya des gens ils vont donner plein de
papiers plein plein plein de papiers et
tous ses papiers que les gens qui te
donne tu l'aimés dans un seul et même
classe r comme ça si un jour il ya un
jour quelqu'un qui te demande en papiers
et quand tu sais que tu là donc il ya
plein de choses comme ça qui m'a appris
les îles et bien j'étais normal est par
contre il a du mal à penser comme on dit
out of the box
il n'est pas très créatif c'est pour ça
que a germé en parallèle de jacques le
normal est heureusement jacques le
rebelle je vous présente jacques le
rebelle donc j'appelle rebelles c'est
tout l'inversé lui remet tout en
question tout le temps quoiqu'il conquis
puis à chaque fois quelque chose il va
il va arriver derrière la ferme et
respectueux et bien sûr par exemple si
j'accède mettons mois jacques je vais
recevoir un cadeau ou jeu l'on va me
faire un compliment il va arriver
jacques le rebelle il va faire inquiète
pas il va te vendre quelque chose
derrière à temps il va venir il va venir
jacques lui normal en fait pour lui
jacques le rebelle pour lui jacques le
normal est une victime pour lui c'est un
mouton dire que de toute façon pour
jacques le rebelle tout le monde est une
victime
le monde entier est une victime d'une
poignée de gens des malveillants qui
arnaquent tout le monde
un système très complexe et l'huile le
sel l'huile et au sud au dessus de ça et
lui il est bien content en ce moment
parce que dans les informations dans les
médias de plus en plus d'éléments qu'il
laisse à penser qu'il n'a pas
complètement tort
en ce moment jacques l'heureux belle île
et il est là et content problème avec
jacques le rebelle c'est que ben ils se
rebellent contre toulon qui peut pas
agir peut rien faire il est ce que
j'appelle compter stationnaire on était
stationnaire il conteste tout mais du
coup il est à retenir parce que dit
qu'il se met à agir et va ça va pas par
exemple il va dire oui il ya de la pub
partout c'est pas possible il ya nous
polluent il faut que les gens se rendent
compte de ça eh ben il va pas en faire
une affiche c'est pas possible c'est oui
on va dire la pollution le réchauffement
climatique c'est pas possible il faut
aller manifester je bouge à paris ah ben
non il peut pas prendre la caisse donc
c'est de base c'est mort et donc c'est
pour ça que intervient 3e jacques qui va
regarder de l'extérieur qui va dire bon
si ces deux là on arrivait à les faire
s'entendre on aurait 2 super bonne idée
on pourrait faire de grandes choses
ça va devenir le but de jacques je vous
présente jacques le compromised jacques
le compromised c'est des bons d'un côté
j'en ai un bon se pose pas de questions
mais au moins il agit il travaille pas
de souci d'autre côté j'en ai un il pige
péter le système va du coup ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va rentrer dans le
système pour mieux le changer et jungle
compromise donc lui fait les compromis
mois il va voir jacques le rebelle il va
lui dire écoute bien falloir que tu
fasse des concessions parce que là tu
fait fumer des joints toute la journée
regarder des documentaires et tu ne fais
rien il va aller voir jacques normal il
va le dire bon t'inquiète je maîtrise
c'est fais moi confiance et un problème
tu m'appelles paquet il va faire une
grande réunion avec les trois jacky va
leur dire pour écouter voilà ce qu'on va
faire les mecs on va prendre un boulot
on va prendre un emploi
ça va être notre gagne-pain et se gagne
pas ça va nous permettre de financer
notre vie ça va nous permettre d'avoir
un appartement ça voilà
et avec l'argent le temps qui nous reste
eh bien on va faire un projet qui nous
tient vraiment à coeur
et c'est jacques le compromised m'a
permis de rentrer dans un équilibre
entre mes deux vagues
du coup les trois qui fait que j'ai pu
avoir un emploi et j'ai pu au fur et à
mesure on revient un peu d'argent
m'acheter la guitare avec laquelle je
vais jouer tout à l'heure et surtout la
guitare avec laquelle j'arrive à écrire
des chansons qui plaisent en même temps
à jacques le rebelle et en même temps à
jacques le normal vous êtes fou quoi
c'est pas comme ça alors en fait voilà
ce qui se passe c'est que ça c'est la
norme sas et le voilà c'est le piège
pour moi c'est en fait c'est le
compromis mais c'est pas un bon
compromis
c'est pas on peut pas fonctionner comme
ça sauf que d'un côté
bah on va au final on va travailler pour
un truc à contrecoeur et de l'autre côté
eh ben on a plus assez d'énergie plus
assez de temps pour faire les choses qui
nous tiennent à coeur
ça devient une espèce de cercle infinie
un cercle sans fin qui amène toujours à
jacques le frustrer alors lui
à lui pas cool je croise dans la rue
c'est jacques le frustré il sait pas
comment faire quoi il se dit voilà la
vie c'est comme ça avec le frustré il
dit il faut bien manger est l'argent
c'est le nerf de la guerre il faut bien
vivre et en fait il a l'impression
parfois tellement il fait des petits
trucs comme des petites actions mais en
fait c'est j'en ai vraiment profondeur
parce que jacques le compromise s'il
n'arrive pas bien à mélanger les deux
premiers jacques le frustré si parfois
il revient vers jacques le compromised
mais un jour il devient jacques le
dépressif jakl dépressif il souffre
il pas bien il pas bien parce qu'il a
tout essayé
il se dit bah en fait la vie c'est comme
ça quoi ces genres voilà je suis né dans
un truc déjà je comprends que dalle ce
qui se passe j'ai pas wallop et voilà
y'a un mec il me dit faire ça à faire ça
je veux faire ça ok en fait à la forme
je suis pas content c'est tout ce qu'ils
voient à lui est plus d'espoir et dès
qu'ils essayent de remettre quelque
chose en question et ben en fait il fait
appel à jacques le rebelle il y mas est
le même c'est le même système
c'est pas vous j'avais le dépressif dans
sa souffrance se dit bon faut que je
fasse quelque chose sinon je vais
devenir jacques le fait divers est là il
fait appel
jacques le penseur
je vous présente jacques le penseur qui
regardent le système de l'extérieur
jacques le penseur qui va arriver il va
penser il va dire bon écoutez vous avez
tout essayé d'accord vous avez tout
remis en question vous avez tout
contester il ya une chose que vous
n'avez pas contesté c'est jacques lui
même vous avez cherché dans jacques les
choses à changer
vous n'avez pas changé jacques lui même
et là il va dire quoi il m'a dit c'est
jacques le concert qui m'a dit ça il m'a
dit moi jacques
en fait je ne suis que la somme de mes
perceptions et que mes perceptions
si j'arrive à maîtriser mes perceptions
alors j'arriverai à maîtriser ma vie
pour jacques le penseur s'il y a un
système il faut rentrer pour mieux le
changer c'est bien le système des
perceptions et la fois ça se retourne en
fait est là on regarde vers l'intérieur
voyez à ségou est en fait jacques
jacques le penseur pour lui il suffit
d'y croire et ça marche bien que le
penseur me dit tu es malheureux à fait
inverse s'est passé pas plus compliqué
que ça et c'est pour ça que jacques le
penseur en fait c'est quelqu'un de très
dangereux il est très très dangereux
d'ailleurs ça se voit regarder puisqu'il
dit c'est vrai mais c'est un peu vrai
par exemple jacques le penseur si je
suis moi je suis malade je vais le voir
il va me dire suffit d'y croire et tu va
guérir on va dire ça à quelqu'un qui est
en chaise roulante va dire ça quelqu'un
de quel cancer il suffit d'y croire tu
va guérir tu vas voir si le mec
l'industrie mais qui va te répond chaque
le penseur il est dangereux et peut
persuader de n'importe quoi il va dire
t'inquiète faut y croire vas-y foncé
vas-y pose ton argent t'inquiète ça va
revenir alors été tu vas tout perdre
faites le penseur tout seul ne va pas
c'est pour ça que arrive
jacques le jongleur jacques longueur
présente pour moi c'est le plus haut
degré de la rébellion
c'est lui le vrai la rebelle
jacques auzou l'heure il n'est pas
content et stationnaires jacques le
jongleur il est contagieux
ouais spontin vieux il spontanée est
contagieux et pas de problème il coule
la mission déjà closes longueur d'angeac
il va accepter la réalité terre à terre
de jacques normal il va y incorporer les
réalités cosmique de jacques le penseur
et avec la créativité de jacques le
rebelle il va essayer de trouver un bon
compromis
mais contrairement à jacques le
compromised jacques longue l'heure pour
lui le compromis est un art et l'art de
jongler à chaque instant entre deux
vérités qui semble paradoxal
notre pensée présente est à la fois la
conclusion de notre vie passée est à la
fois le point de départ de notre vie
future
ceci était à la fois mon point de départ
et nous sert ce soir de conclusion
on va jongler un peu maman
[Musique]
et
il y a des choses qui se disent et
d'autres qui ne se disent pas
il y a des choses qui existent on se
connaît déjà
[Musique]
moi je vous ai tous dit
puisque vous saviez déjà
[Musique]
et j'ai fait comme si
je vous parlais de moi
hé hé hé hé
[Musique]
oh
ce que je dis c'est vrai
ce n'est pas que vrai
ce que tu comprends c'est faux mais ce
n'est pas me faut
tu crois que c'est prévu en fait c'est
de l'impro
tu crois que c'est génétique en fait
c'est placebo
et m
[Musique]
m
j'ai perdu l'habitude de prendre des
habitudes
gc la pluie dans l'âme et
on va quand même pas passer par la
fenêtre
me demande bien où en sont les voisins
hé hé
[Musique]
m
si vous avez compris le fond de mon
message
faites le moi savoir
s'il vous plaît ne m'applaudissaient pas
je trouve que le silence est bien plus
beau à voir
alors s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
gadr le maintenant